When is the coldest time of year?
That's right, it's winter!
Can we still go outside to play?
No problem, there are many fun things to do outside in winter.
What is your favorite thing to do in the snow?
Skiing?
Sledding?
Snowball Fights?
Put on your warm clothes and get ready for an adventure.
What does this little girl like to do in the snow?
That's right, she made a friendly snowman.
It is hard work to roll up each big ball of snow.
How many snowballs did she use?
Can you guess what she used for his arms, nose, eyes and mouth?
I count three big snowballs for his body.
Oh, look!
He has sticks for arms, marbles for his eyes and mouth,...
...and a carrot for his nose.
This snowman even has a hat and scarf.
Does this snowman look happy with his new friend?
Maybe his name is Frosty.